battalion along europe's eastern flank
the latest deployment of american
soldiers
the order and ceremony in such contrast
to an upending of world order which
feels at least so real
these soldiers are among a number
growing fast here in latvia to defend
the nato alliance
in brussels a tap on the back for the
alliance's secretary-general from
hungary's prime minister victor orban
once seen as close to putin but now in
lockstep with his fellow european
leaders united in disgust
we are
facing a new normal in european security
where russia openly contests the
european security order
but on the question of more nato
defensive weaponry for ukraine missiles
to shoot down russian planes listen to
his careful language we all realize that
of course in this very evolving and uh
and uh and the
difficult situation it's hard to predict
what would be the
what
what what are the possibilities in the
future but allies are providing support
and are very committed to continue to
provide support
individually providing support not nato
itself a hopeful nuance an attempt not
to provoke a putin they cannot read
the american president meanwhile was
trying to focus on the business of
domestic politics filling a supreme
court vacancy
it was left to his spokesperson to catch
up with the eu in the uk in announcing
sanctions on putin himself
the president is doing nearly everything
in his power to lead the world and stand
up against the actions of president
putin what he will not do is send u.s
troops to fight in ukraine because he is
not going to put the american public the
american people or the united states in
a position of fighting a war with russia
and that's the nub of it that's why nato
forces will not roll into ukraine to end
all this it is about sanctions now
against putin himself freezing his
assets potentially banning him from
traveling
tactics that were once a deterrent now
feel so reactionary and against a man
who isn't listening
up in new york diplomatic solidarity for
ukraine and a resolution to condemn
russia and call for it to get out of the
country
russia's power of veto ensures it fails
but it is a message from the top
diplomatic body of the world cementing
isolation for russia and its president
vladimir putin mark stone sky news in
washington